[Music]
hello everyone
so uh in the previous part of our
discussion
we had arrived at this equation this
fourth order equation
uh and before proceeding
with some ideas about solving this
this fourth order equation let me just
say that
this del 4 this is referred to
as the by harmonic operator okay so
so just like the del square is referred
to as the laplacian operator
this del 4 is referred to as the by
harmonic operator sometimes also as the
by laplacian
okay uh furthermore you note
that we had expanded this del 4 phi
in terms of this x and y upon
the partial derivatives with respect to
x and y but that is true only in the
rectangular cartesian coordinate system
in a cylindrical coordinate system uh
this form will be
something completely different again the
spherical coordinate system it will be
something completely different
but right now we don't have to worry
about all that now
very relevant to our current course of
mechanics of solids
uh what we need to note is that
uh and as i had already mentioned in the
previous part of the lecture that
uh when we are solving a problem through
the air stress function approach
uh it it must be true that we
that the boundary conditions are
properly considered okay
so what is actually done okay in terms
of solving
uh the problem what is actually done
find this
this we have in a very general form that
we have this uh
by harmonic operator operating on the a
stress function
uh sounds very sophisticated uh and also
note that
this equation itself is referred to as
the by harmonic equation
very famous equation uh but
but in actual operational terms what do
we do okay
so what we do is this that we assume
okay so
operational steps
we assume some general form for this
fight
okay some general solution form assume
some general solution form
next you find out the conditions which
must be satisfied
uh that must be satisfied
find the conditions that must be
satisfied
for this general solution form to
satisfy this by harmonic equation
so when i am writing in this in words
like this it may
sound all very abstract but we'll take
some
concrete examples to illustrate what i'm
talking about here
okay so that's the second step next
satisfy the boundary conditions
now please note that although i have
written these things in sequence
in an actual problem-solving scenario
sometimes
what what can happen is that the
the presence of certain boundary
conditions may guide us
in choosing the general solution forms
also okay that can happen
but uh usually this is this is the the
sequence
now what do we do with this general
solution form this is a very vague term
okay so again operationally speaking
what is done
is uh and is very common in this
stress function approach is to consider
some kind of polynomial general
forms for phi okay so uh
let me just illustrate that
so it's usual to consider
polynomial forms for phi
okay so uh so
let's say that you take something like
phi is equal to
uh ax square or phi equal to a y square
uh y equal to a y cube things like that
okay uh
and it may also be true that uh these
may
combine uh various powers of x and y
together
okay so you can also have things like pi
equal to t times
x times y okay all of these can happen
but let us not get into that all of them
together
rather just let us take them one by one
so for example suppose we take
uh
i is equal to some constant
okay now before proceeding any further
uh let me just mention one very
important thing
uh which is that
up right now
okay it is very much possible to go into
very systematic
uh structured way of presenting this
discussion
that would be quite lengthy
okay but i really don't want to get into
that sort of things
it was i had done that myself or some of
the earlier semesters
uh but uh
but my feeling and uh based on based on
the experiences
is that uh perhaps it's best to give
some
uh short examples uh to
that also reduces the coverage of the
syllabus certainly which is extremely
important especially in this
pandemic scenario
plus through these small examples of we
can illustrate
things in a nicer cleaner fashion okay
so let me go with this
reduced coverage uh but at the same time
trying to illustrate the key important
points
okay otherwise this this chapter on 2d
elasticity
is actually probably the the longest
chapter
in all of mechanics of solids okay so
we'll not get into that much detail all
right
so suppose if we take phi is equal to
constant okay what is the implication of
that
well implication is that you can
immediately understand
that sigma x x is equal to 0
sigma x y equal to 0 and sigma yy
is equal to 0 okay so this is not very
interesting
but you note that in terms of our
operational steps we have taken some
polynomial form
but the powers of x and y are 0
and we have actually managed
to ensure that if it if we
substitute this phi in the biharmonic
equation it is very much solved i mean
it is it is satisfied trivially but it
is satisfied
okay and uh we have this kind of a thing
that the stresses are zero
which so shows us that this is uh this
is a solution to a not very interesting
kind of problem so we don't have to
worry too much about it
next let's say we have i is
equal to ax
okay so again if we have this thing
we get back a sigma xx equal to 0 sigma
xy equal to 0 sigma yy equal to 0
because you know that sigma xx is del
square phi
del y square okay so this is not going
to give us anything the sigma yy
has a derivative with respect to x but
it's a second derivative so
again this is not going to give us
anything all right
uh similarly for the sigma x y
again similarly if you take instead of a
x if you take something like a y
and please note that this a is just a
constant okay we don't have to worry
about it instead of ax if we take a y
it's the same scenario sigma x x equal
to zero sigma x y equal to zero sigma y
y equal to zero
okay in fact if you take a combination
of this
ax plus b y let's say then also it's the
same scenario
okay so it's not very interesting can we
end up with sigma xx
equal to sigma xy is equal to sigma yy
equal to 0. next suppose we take
a second degree okay then
something nice may come out let's try
that
a y square then sigma x x
is equal to del square phi del y square
ah so here we have something non-zero
finally
okay so this is a constant value but at
least it's non-zero
uh sigma yy however that is still zero
and sigma xy well that is 0 also
because this is minus del square phi del
x del y
this is going to give us 0 so we have a
situation
where if we take if we proceed with this
particular form a y
square then the stress field in the
entire body
will come out to be a constant
okay so you see what we are doing here
in the process of taking this particular
form
we have not actually talked about any
partic any specific problem
and this is this is uh this is a
a method which is applied in widely in
this
area stress function approach okay so
the next few
sentences that i am going to utter you
please note down
this very very carefully i mean these
are operational truths
uh what is really done is that
people take this or what has been done
is this
is that people have taken these kinds of
various uh forms
okay various polynomial forms and they
have seen that okay if you take this
kind of a y square you end up with sigma
x x equal to constant
maybe if you take a x square instead of
a y square then you get sigma y y equal
to constant
now all this is just a mathematical
uh kind of discussion but which problem
are we solving
okay so it's like putting the card
before the horse okay
just a reverse way of thinking of the
thing we first find a solution
this is a solution okay because you know
that this phi it very much satisfies the
by harmonic equation okay so by harmonic
equation this is very much satisfied
here also
okay please note all of these things
okay otherwise it would have been
completely wrong to discuss any of these
forms
so here also the by harmonic equation
del 4 phi equal to 0
that is satisfied for this case
certainly it is satisfied
okay in all everything that we are
discussing the pi harmonic equation that
is being perfectly satisfied
that is satisfied which means that the
stress equilibrium equations are
satisfied the compatibility equations
are satisfied and we are getting
some kind of valid forms of the stresses
now the question is
which problem are we solving we have
arrived at solutions
but we don't know which problem we are
solving so it's like
i mean getting the answer and then
trying to find the question it's a
reverse way
okay it may seem a little bit weird and
ridiculous but that's the way it is done
and it has been done like that okay so
to think of think of a physical
situation where the stress field may
actually turn out to be a constant like
this and you are all aware of this
from your first year mechanics so let's
just quickly discuss this bit
uh go to the next page
you consider a
a thin plate
okay a thin rectangular plate where the
thickness
is within the is going into the into the
plane of the screen
so we can't see that and let's say it is
being loaded
by this kind of a tensile force
okay now if you take a cut section
like this let me take that in a better
fashion
like this then you know that the average
normal stresses there
would be just uh the t divided by the
cross
cross sectional area of that that part
okay similarly you take any other cross
section
perpendicular to the longitudinal axis
of this plate uh
you will end up with the same value of
the average normal stresses
so perhaps this gives us a clue that
this is the problem
that our previous area stress function
that we had just discussed
in the previous page here that this phi
equal to
a y square this is the problem that we
are actually
uh addressing through that area stress
function okay
because uh here the see if if
our or x x axis is like this
okay uh let's say our y axis is like
this
then sigma xx is indeed a constant here
okay and you see how
uh the particular form of
the general form so again going back to
the previous page
this a y square is the general form of
the general polynomial form that we have
assumed at the beginning
what we don't know is this value of a
and if we come to this specific problem
we know that this constant value will be
something like
t by a
and since we have found our sigma xx
maybe
a different variable for this a cross
sectional area
so let's say the cross-sectional area is
given by
uh by small a
right so this is the cross-sectional
area
okay just not too confused with the
constant a that i had taken earlier
and because we have obtained that sigma
xx is equal to
del square phi del y square is equal to
a from the previous page because phi was
a y square
so we can set this equal to t by a
which means that our a becomes this and
because
we have said that the general solution
form is phi equal to a y square
it means that our general solution form
is e
t by a y square okay this is this is our
thing
furthermore you note that the moment you
obtain this sigma xx
also you know about sigma yy equal to
zero and sigma x y equal to zero
let's write that down my x y equal to
zero
okay which is sensible if you look back
at this problem the sigma yy is
you indeed expect it to be zero and the
sigma xy is also zero 0
from this from these pieces of
information you can actually obtain the
epsilon x6
okay 1 by e sigma xx
minus nu sigma yy
that is the young's modulus of course so
sigma x6 we have already found it to be
equal to
uh t by a
so we have this as the as the answer for
our epsilon x x
similarly for epsilon yy we have 1 by e
sigma yy minus nu sigma
xx so that will give us
minus nu by e uh
t by a
all right so um the
expressions of epsilon x x and epsilon y
were also constant
now from these two pieces of information
and using the strain
displacement relations we can actually
find out
uh the the strength
the the displacement fields u and v okay
the u along the x direction and the v
along the
y direction we can find out those
displacement fields
and we have already seen how to do those
given certain
uh certain expressions for epsilon x x
epsilon y y and epsilon x y
in the kinematics chapter problem sheet
okay so you see how everything is
connected together
okay so there without caring about
anything about the loading about the
solution of the various pro
governing equations that may be
connected to the loading
you were given certain strain fields and
from that you were asked to find out
this
displacement fields and now you see that
given a certain problem
uh starting from very general notions
which which contain all the information
about the compatibility
about the the stress equilibrium
equations you are able to arrive at
these things
and from these you can find out the
displacement phase
okay so from here you can find out u and
v please also note that although i have
not written it here
the epsilon x y is going to be equal to
0
because that is directly connected to
sigma x y and sigma x y is 0.
so from these things u and v can be
found out
of course there is a little bit of a
of a discussion required for this i
really want
you to go ahead and check this when you
when you
find out this u and v you will see that
you can only find that out
uh only up to correct only up to
some constants okay so some constants
will remain
um unsolved okay
and if you go back to the problem sheet
on kinematics you will see
that those that is exactly the kind of
situation you had ended up in one of the
problems
okay so terms which which basically
represent
the rigid body displacement or the or
the rigid body rotation
those things remain unknown okay so
those things will be known
only if some extra conditions are given
to us you see here
we have not been said that where this
plate is hanging
okay it's like floating in space that
cannot be really true
okay so it has to be fixed in some place
and only then we can apply some loading
on it so perhaps
this corner is fixed to some place or
maybe that corner is fixed to some place
or maybe this edge is fixed to some
place maybe
it's attached to some kind of a wall or
a something like that
maybe it is clamped to something okay so
that will give us
some kind of conditions which are
referred to as fixity conditions
uh and from those pieces of information
we can actually go on
to find out the the the extra
on the unknown constants present in this
u
unp
but that is actually a discussion
relevant for the kinematics chapter
which you have already done
okay next let us consider
another example
so what i want to do now is consider
this but this general form y is equal to
a y cube what happens now
let's see the pawn for sigma xx
sigma xx will be del square pi del y
square
so uh if i do uh
the first derivative i end up with 3 a y
square and if i do the second derivative
i end up with 6 a y ok this is
interesting now
because you see that earlier i was
getting the constant value
but now because of the presence of this
cubic power
i am ending up with the linear
dependence of the sigma xx
on the y okay so
next as usual we check the and the
expressions for sigma yy
uh it's del square phi del x square so
that's very much zero
and sigma x y
that is also zero okay
so the only thing to be concerned with
is this 6 a y
and again we have done something
ridiculous like we have taken this
general form without
regard to any specific problem and now
we have ended up with these kinds of
interesting strain stresses stress
fields
and then the and then we we ask
ourselves the question
which is the problem which this stress
field is actually solving
okay so it turns out okay we are not
going to go into the details of it
that this kind of a stress field is
basically the solution to a pure bending
problem
okay and let me just give you a hint uh
because something uh you are kind of
familiar with
back in first year mechanics you had
perhaps done a number of beam problems
and there you found out that the
flexural loading
stress okay the flexural stress or the
bending stress
it came out in this form the sigma xx
was like this so
near the top in the top half of the of
the beam cross section the sigma x6 was
inside in nature and in the bottom half
it was
compressive in nature
okay so this
is where your sigma xx if you
consider your y to be like this the
sigma xx
is indeed proportional to y okay
so suppose this is our our beam center
line
then the y is positive here and the y is
negative here and you can understand how
this
thing will will correlate with this
okay so uh so this kind of a solution
that we obtained from the airy stress
function approach is basically
solving this pure bending problem which
you had to solve by different
by different route back in first year
mechanics
now in if you if in your mind
uh it appears that this is all wrong
we should not be doing like this okay so
this is
this is an absolutely ridiculous way of
proceeding with the
uh with the problem that we
that we are finding solutions and then
looking for uh
and looking for problems which this may
solve
and again as i said this is indeed true
this is ridiculous
okay but what has happened in practice
is that
people people have done done this uh
this kind of a trial and error business
uh
to a large extent for us okay and people
have developed a
very long large catalog of solutions
together with the problems that they are
solving okay
so this information is is present
to us or is available to us as a rich
repository in various textbooks
various uh
various monographs and these are being
used routinely
okay so
there is a lot of trial and error but
there is also
a certain uh basis in this trial and
error
okay because it's not just all haphazard
whatever is being done here is uh
is very much connected to the real
physical problems that are being solved
and
one may actually
compare this with the culinary arts okay
so
when you go into a kitchen and you try
to invent a new recipe
you have to do a little bit of trial and
error in fact a lot of trial and error
uh and only then you will arrive at
something
something nice okay but the ultimate
test of of all that niceness and
cleverness will be how it tastes okay so
then to draw proper i mean to go forward
with the analogy
so all of this cleverness associated
with eddy stress function approach and
everything
will work out only if it solves actually
solves a real physical problem
similarly in the culinary arts uh your
recipe clever recipe is only going to
work out if it tastes good
okay and so in a way and this trial and
error business even though it may
seem very very dirty it's still better
than
what what passes off as a modern art in
some context
but uh let me not digress too much now
we have uh talked up to the cubic
root okay what happens if we take the
fourth root now the sorry the fourth
power okay
well uh let me just give you
a an example where we take
uh perhaps where we considered all the
terms okay
so uh let's say
what i mean by all the terms is that
when i say
fourth power i can consider
my constants like this
so this is not actually a 40 this is a40
what i mean is that this is the
coefficient of such a term
where the power on the x is 4 and the
power on the y is 0.
okay so this is like y to the power 0
which is why i'm not writing it here
next i have
the one so each of the terms that i'm
writing
is of a fourth degree okay so the total
index power here is
four
i have next a22 where it is x square y
square plus a 1 3
x y cube plus
a 0 4
where the power of x is 0 and the power
of y is
4. now we have to be little bit careful
you see earlier whenever we are talking
about
the various general forms of the
eddystress function
starting out in this page here
as phi equal to constant we have seen
that it satisfies the bi-harmonic
equation identically
here also when we took ax or a y or ax
plus b y it satisfied the bi-harmonic
equation identically
and here also it's satisfied identically
similarly if you consider
this phi equal to a y cube this also
satisfies
the by harmonic equation identically
but what about this okay so
we'll see that if we use this here
this is not satisfied identically okay
so this is where we need to be careful
especially
as regards to the second operational
step which i had mentioned earlier
on this page okay so among the
operational steps i had mentioned that
find the conditions that must be
satisfied for the general solution form
to satisfy this by harmonic equation for
the for the lower
uh powers of the polynomials we did not
have to worry but for
first for this fourth degree polynomial
i really have to
be worried about this okay
so uh this is just an algebra kind of
thing so you try to find out
the conditions which will be necessary
to
satisfy this by harmonic equation now
as a general information let me tell you
that
this kind of fourth power is not just a
mathematical exercise
there there are very relevant problems
for um which are of interest to you
uh that are satisfied by this fourth
degree polynomials
uh for example the cantilever beam
the problem for the cantilever beam
under
a tip loading so this kind of a problem
okay where we have this cantilever beam
a beam basically clamped to a wall
under some kind of loading at the end so
this problem
would be satisfied or would be solved by
a fourth fourth degree uh polynomial
of course all the terms will not be
there okay
so uh in our problem sheet uh we will be
discussing
uh a few interesting cases like this
uh uh we can have uh
even going further a a polynomial form
involving the fifth degree and as you
can imagine there will be lot more terms
there
but uh specific to certain problems we
can find out
or so or first of all we have to find
out the conditions that must be
satisfied
for this bioharmonic equation to be
satisfied and then specific to prob
to the particular physical situations we
can
find out the various constant values
depending on the boundary conditions
now in earlier semesters i had given uh
full-fledged problems on this but maybe
in this pandemic scenario
i refrain from doing that now maybe one
example or so
uh what what is more important what i
really want you to learn
as part of this chapter is uh is the is
the important condition that must be
satisfied
and the the overall spirit in which uh
we use this air stress
function okay so with that uh i conclude
this
chapter all right uh thank you very much